Speaker 1: Another legal story that popped up over
the weekend, the Republican Party itself. The RNC
has agreed to pay one point six million dollars
worth of Donald Trump's legal fees for the ongoing
investigations taking place into Trump and the
Trump Organization in the state of New York. Now,
The Washington Post broke this story, and
they described it as a highly unusual move.
After all, Donald Trump is not a candidate right
now. He's not even a representative of the RNC.
He's not a sitting politician, he's just a
retired guy sitting in Florida playing golf.
And the Republican Party has decided to step in
and say, you know what, we understand you got some
bad things happening up in New York. How about
we help you out a little bit, right? How does 1.6
million dollars sound for your legal fees, Mr.
Billionaire? That's the part that really blows
my mind about this is doesn't Donald Trump have
an estimated net worth of like $10 billion? Ten
billion, 1.6 million, that's nothing for him. Of
course, Trump will take it. You know, he would
love for everybody else to pay his legal fees
so he doesn't have to spend a dime on it, but.
Why would you even need to pay
a billionaire's legal fees?
Maybe he's not actually worth a billion, I don't
know. I haven't seen his financial statements.
Prosecutors in New York have
so that's going to be fun.
But this is highly unusual, right? The Washington
Post is correct. This is a highly unusual move.
This is not something that happens all the
time. Well, this isn't something that happens.
So this is weird. Why would the RNC step in
and agree to pay this billionaire's legal fees
for an issue that's not even related to politics
in an investigation that technically hasn't even
accused Donald Trump of any wrongdoing at
all? Nothing about this makes any sense,
because, again, Trump has not even been accused
of anything. This is an issue that doesn't involve
politics. But the RNC came out this is via GOP
spokesperson Emma Vaughn, who said quote as a
leader of our party defending President Trump and
his record of achievement is critical to the GOP.
It is entirely appropriate for the RNC to continue
assisting in fighting back against the Democrats,
never ending witch hunt and attacks on
him. So even though it's not political,
they've gone and made it political because that is
their political strategy. See, now we're kind of
getting to the heart of what's actually happening
here. Republicans, the Republican Party itself,
the establishment of it have decided if Trump is
going to be our guy, we got to protect our guy.
And if he's going to be the guy that
the next person latches themselves on
to and models themself after, we still
have to protect him. Because of his
empire, of his image that he has created gets
destroyed. Then we get destroyed. We have become
inseparable from this man. So we do have to
protect him, even from something that doesn't
involve politics. And we have to frame it as a way
that makes us not look like we're desperate. So
we'll claim there's a witch hunt. We'll try to
dismiss it to the American public, saying, Oh,
this is the Democrats going after this guy because
they hate him so much because he's a threat to
their party. He's a winner. They're losers,
even though we all know the opposite there.
But that's what they're doing. They're doing it
not to protect him, but to protect themselves